my dad used to say to me
when I was young and I you know when I
was in college I'd say you know I'm
going to do this and that he'd be like
yeah you can do that and if you don't
you'll come work with me so I had like
this
fall back work for Dad thing if this
doesn't work out but honestly I would
just say to him no no I'm going to be
fine I'm going to make it I'm going to
do good he'd be like all right he'd look
at me like I was a little nuts my mother
on the other hand was just like oh he's
going to be wonderful because she
thought I was every move I made was
great and then my father man when he
laughed boy you were excited you were
excited that the big man was good and
thought it was funny because he was a
smart guy and he always
he always you know certain comedians
made him laugh I used to love any
comedian my father and mother liked boy
there was so so many people that my
parents one day would watch him on
Johnny Carson I'd be like oh God I want
to be like that guy he's making my dad
happy